just the news says Arizona judge
approves Kerry Lake's request to examine
ballots the inspection is slated to
begin at 8 A.M next Tuesday this really
surprised me it really surprised me
judge Peter Thompson on Thursday issued
the ruling which allows the inspection
of random ballots in the in the county
ahead of the trial date the Republican
had previously filed a request to do so
and Arizona law provides for candidate
challenging election results to demand
ballot inspections to prepare so uh
Thompson granted three of Lake's four
demands allowing the inspection of 50
random ballot on-demand printed ballots
50 random early ballots and 50 random
bod ballots marked spoiled the judge
denied her bid to inspect 50 50 random
early ballot envelopes which is weird
but either way this is huge this is
Carrie Lake's election contest moving
forward to an evidentiary point now
there is in the ruling that if the if if
the case is dismissed then this is
vacated basically
but uh with Trump in 2020 all almost all
of the court cases that they had were
dismissed on standing
you can't do that here Arizona law
prescribes for this kind of action so I
don't know exactly what they're going to
find but there's already witness
testimony coming out you know uh as as
evidence and with Carrie Lake being
granted the ability to inspect these
random ballots what she wants to do is
50 ballots from each different place so
this may actually be 50 random 50 uh 50
random Battle On Demand 50 random bod 50
early and it could be at like every
different place in Maricopa County so I
guess my my question is I wonder what
ultimately will come from this and I
don't really know what else to say from
it I'll say about it other than I think
this is this is massive still could
potentially result in nothing if carry
like is wrong about everything but what
do you think happens just hypothetically
they've already certified Katie Hobbs
has certified her own election for in
favor of herself for winning but what
happens then to to YouTube's rules what
happens to Twitter's misinformation
rules if next week on the 20th they do
the random inspection and find like a 17
inaccuracy or something some people have
already pointed out there was one post
that a three percent margin of error is
greater than the margin of victory that
means if they do these random samplings
and find a very small sample of of bad
counts
something then what happens
I mean I don't know where to go with
this one I'm just like it's big I mean
it depends on like Arizona's law right
if it's big enough well it depends on
the judge really right and if it's a
random sampling like if if enough of
them are messed up at some point like we
need to study a bigger slash maybe all
of them I mean this is the thing that
could take a really long time to get
clarification on at a certain point like
I hope that Carrie lake has enough
backers willing to you know donate to
her legal fund because this is going to
be an ongoing fight for a long time
imagine
the 21st comes around they have the
trial because that was the trial date
this is 20 and 21st I think the 21st the
20th and 21st what happens if a ju if
the judge issues a stay on Katie Hobbs
becoming Governor just like the
political ramifications or whatever that
means would be crazy that's why yes so
then who's Governor right Deuce Doug
ducey's yeah he just stays in office the
thing is they get done I've got a
normalcy bias I cannot imagine that
happening because it would be so
shocking to all of us but if it does
oh man but I don't think Carol Lake's
gonna give up I think she will push you
until the end and so like it is going to
be on Hobbs and I guess the election
officials in Arizona to either be like
no we have enough evidence to prove
you've been a loss or they're gonna have
to acquiesce that there was something
wrong but what I kind of you know here's
where I'm at right now with this
there's a lot of people who are
screaming fraud and all that stuff and
I'm like I don't know about that but I
am willing to bet that with universal
mail-in voting and the way they handle
this they're not doing signature
signature verification as rigorously as
they used to which means I would not be
surprised if Kerry Lake can actually
find a percentage high enough through
the random sampling to at least throw
everything into question which could
result in what a stay of you know her
being inaugurated whatever the word is
or or or or then what a new election how
would they deal with this I mean this is
crazy I also would really like to know
the judge's reasoning behind not
allowing the early the envelopes yeah I
know that's kind of weird it is weird
just be like sure look at the envelope
whatever right I don't know unless
they're they don't maintain the
envelopes like there's if all the
counties don't have a consistent policy
and what the envelopes like maybe you
can't get 50 random samplings this is
just speculation on land also this makes
me want everyone to read their States
laws regarding elections like if there's
a close election in your state what does
your state allow you you to do because
like without this law it'd be really
easy to just deny care like her day in
court here's here's here's something I
think people should consider too I don't
know what's going to happen in this it's
in court we'll see but you have to
imagine with everything that happened in
2020 and the accusations about Arizona
that carry a like behind the scenes was
was was placing those chess pieces in
the right order you can't be someone who
believes Trump was right about 2020 and
not
cross your t's dot your eyes and do
everything possible to make sure that
when this happens
surprise surprise Carrie lake is now in
The Fray challenging it she tried she
tried suing Earl way before the election
saying the machines need you know need
need to work and they said no standing
because the election didn't happen then
we had the tabulation error and she sued
saying I told you so it's like the fact
the court system operates that way is
broken as it is yeah but I I'm willing
to bet that Carrie like Trump's allies
probably put a bunch of money into into
planning for a legal maneuver after the
election because they expected something
like this yeah it's also frustrating
though to watch her being painted as
this crazy conspiracy theorist you know
because of her history of questioning
previous things uh that's all I'll say
on that but
um it's frustrating because it just
feels like such gaslighting that they're
like oh look here She is again
questioning another election she's crazy
she's never going to you know abide by
democracy whatever they want to call it
and so I think like it's just
frustrating to watch her being gaslit
because here you see she has Merit when
she came out and she gave that big long
uh I think it was her last video that
she did where she detailed what all is
involved in the lawsuit I mean if she
can back that up if what she had if what
she's saying she actually has that's
huge yeah I mean she's saying they just
randomly came up with all of these
thousands of votes out of nowhere you
know they found them and something is
wrong or whatever right I don't know
though they're like there there's some
claim that a witness said they saw about
from a dead person I don't know about
all that that's what the court is for
but if that turned out to be true that
this is why I say normalcy by it's like
ah come on like if that actually was
exposed in court and they like couldn't
deny it it would the whole country would
erupt it would be the craziest thing
ever I but I gotta be honest
we're getting close to 2028 you know
fourth turning and all that you got the
antifa guys in in Georgia who are uh
that story about the antifa guys they
were setting homes on houses on fire
they they uh a guy was in his truck and
they started bashing it he jumped out
they flipped it and set it on fire so
like you know when you hear stories
about antifa doing that kind of stuff
and that's now antifess and autonomous
Zone in Georgia right now and it's just
not being reported on probably because
people are just like oh yeah it's normal
now it is normal to hear stories of
antifa setting up autonomous zones I
literally I literally had no idea that
that was happening yep in Georgia like
today right yeah five of them got
charged with terrorism just okay like
the other day they just and so that
autonomous Zone's been there and we
don't even know about it because it's
just no journalist cares nobody's
nobody's tracking it nobody's reporting
on it they can't really You Know cover
it because you know they get beat up if
they do sure sure also they're
anti-fascists so they're the good guys
right right I don't think you understand
yeah I know but my point is it's become
normal yeah come on if you went back
even four years and said that far left
extremists would be seizing parts of
their cities and creating up creating
autonomous jurisdictions people would
laugh at you and call you nuts and now
it's it's it's happening you know I
don't want to say it happening all the
time but it happened again and we had no
idea they were doing it well there I
mean they're normalizing degeneracy just
all across the board though it's not
just with antifa it's with you know I go
back to the sexualization of children
and things like that they you show them
something that's sexually explicit and
they're like yeah what's the problem
it's just completely normal to them
they're they're they're gutting the
culture of America
they did gut it and as I was saying
earlier I think the main issue is that
for any Corporation for any law
enforcement there is no upside to
standing up for America and independents
and conservatives
yeah they're not going to do anything if
you defy the left they will attack you
they will try to kill you they will burn
down your store if you defy the right
conservatives Grumble on Twitter not
only that like if they go after the far
right everyone cheers if they go to
conservatives conservatives back off and
complain if they go after the left and
liberals antifa shows up with crowbars
baseball bats and mount off cocktails
and it's frustrating too because being
in you know uh the kind of the activism
Community I'm constantly like guys we
are in the spot in society where we are
because everyone sat at home and didn't
do anything right you kept your families
you minded your own business you said ah
Live and Let Live I'm just gonna mind my
own business and meanwhile the left took
culture and we see how much they eroded
it so now when I go to them and I say
are you ready do you want it do you want
to get active they're like well no
because now this is the culture and I
might get fired right I can't
participate because if my boss finds out
that I'm a conservative they might can
me and then and I have to feed my family
so what's the answer but it's only
because conservatives don't stand up
that exists I know that's what I'm
saying right so you're stuck in this
cycle of like well he's gonna do it
right that's why I'm saying
I'm saying all the
stop it we are here because you guys
said I'm going to sit around and mind my
own business and let the left do
whatever they want these Libertarians I
tell you okay
you want to start this again let's go
let's go right now do you see what Dave
Smith tweeted uh uh he said Tim pool
Michael null Tim cast Michael Knowles
and Luke aren't allowed to talk about
libertarian Community without me or
Michael Mouse present it was it was it
was three on one uh and uh I I thought a
lot about the stuff that we we talked
about I thought I could do a lot better
but specifically when it comes to what
you were just mentioning there should
also be a lot of blame on the Bush
Administration I think the Bush
Administration pushed a lot more people
to the left and I think they were like
hey we can't have these crazy people
starting we're stealing all the money
giving all the money to halliburn
screwing over the soldiers and screwing
over the American people spending more
money than they ever had I think the
Bush Administration truly wasn't
listening to Libertarians wasn't
influenced by Libertarians was uh an
Administration that truly put us on this
path that we are right now setting up a
deep State setting up a war on Terror
that now is being turned around against
Republicans and conservatives so uh you
know to make to the point to to
Michael's points even last night he
specifically said oh it's Libertarians
that created a situation where
conservatives are this bad no it was it
was Republicans and conservatives that
screwed themselves and created this
situation that there was a bigger
pushback against uh he also mentioned
specifically Vietnam if you look at uh
and uh the cultural revolution in the
60s what spurred that on Vietnam the
assassination of JFK which the
government by the way the CIA is still
keeping thousands of documents secret as
of today not finding out exactly what
happened there and it was also the CIA
that was also dosing people with acid
pushing a cultural revolution so there's
a lot of different things to kind of
examine here and take a step back when
it comes to blaming everything on
Libertarians I'm I'm triggered so I'm
gonna read this chat comment uh I'm not
necessarily triggered but uh Stone says
Mr millionaire Tim Poole you have you
have to risk it all and um the way I
interpret that is like I'm doing really
really well and there's little risk so
there's an old story about the sort of
Damocles I'm sure y'all have heard it
right the dude goes to the king and says
oh how glorious it would be to be king
and he says how about I let you sit in
the throne for one day and be king he
says oh joy would be me and then when he
goes and sits in the throne he looks up
and there's a sword hanging from a
single horse's a horse's hair right
above his head and he goes I don't want
to sit here anymore and he was like you
think that sitting in the throne is real
great Until you realize everyone's
trying to kill you so um what does it
mean to risk it all it's a good question
we certainly are comfortable because of
the success of the show and I really do
appreciate everybody who's made that
possible but uh there's also a bullet
hole in my kitchen because two men
targeting us smashed through the window
and climbed in and that was actually not
even the first incident I can't talk
about the other ones there's also some
other things I can't talk about that
happen today because if I went and told
you about every single time someone
committed a very serious crime against
us then that's probably all we would
ever talk about so risking it all I mean
this is the way I kind of see it which
is is frustrating I understand for the
for the average person it's very
difficult to to step into The Fray to
say to their company no I get it you
know I don't have a family that's that's
one risk I don't have and you do
and you're willing to bow to the corrupt
and the evil if it means shielding your
children uh for the time being but the
end result I suppose is just going to be
your kids living under the same boot
for me man and I mean honestly for for
everybody who's here and works here when
someone shows up and and breaks in or
sends us death threats or we get you
know my family gets threatening phone
calls I kind of feel like we are taking
big risks doing all this when we could
probably just make like a gaming channel
and you know walk away from everything
so I've talked about it before where it
would be so much easier just to quit
retire
take whatever I've got and just go live
in the mountains and say I am done the
risk isn't worth it but I can't do that
the risk is what comes like the risk is
what we accept in order to fight the
fight in order to challenge this and
that means that uh I have to obfuscate
my location it means that there's
probably gonna be more people who try
and break into my house and who do break
into my house and there's going to be
more gunshots and eventually there will
be critical injury from it and things
will get crazy
I can walk away from all that I guess if
I didn't want to risk it so I kind of
Envy the people who are sitting you know
at their house you know they're playing
video games with their kids thinking I'm
not going to say anything and I get what
they're saying but far be it for me to
be the person take the risk I'm jealous
of that you know I'd probably just
prefer to go to the skate park every day
and then just you know I could have
taken the money I got from Disney when I
worked for him and never had to work and
just lived in a van and said screw you
guys you're on your own so I don't know
man it's kind of how I feel about it I
think that like to a certain extent you
are open it's easy for people to
criticize you that you don't take enough
risk they don't really see all the risks
that you do that you take and it's a
trickle-down effect everyone at our
company takes but I would go one step
further and say you have to think of
that Ronald Reagan quote all great
change in America starts at the dinner
table like you are in a position to take
greater risk because you have you know a
bigger public platform you might have
more resources but like if people are
not at home with their children
discussing like openly what their values
are and what values they want their
children to carry into the future it
doesn't matter how many risks every
public figure takes right like if we
don't live our principles day by day you
could take as many risks and put
yourself in danger all the time but
ultimately the influence is limited like
people have the ability to take risks
themselves even if it's not standing up
to their boss but to be open with their
children I can't tell you how many
people I know don't discuss what
American culture is with their families
they say well we we don't want to talk
politics with our children we don't want
to talk about our history like there are
risks that and opportunities for people
every day you don't have to have a ton
of money or a huge following on the
internet to do this like you have to
live your values and I think that's why
I don't know it's it's a it's hard
because you do take a lot of risk but
also like you do it because you believe
in what you're doing people can take
these risks in their personal lives be
more open with their friends about what
they believe or what they won't tolerate
they just choose not to because it's
uncomfortable I also yeah you know I I
dealt with a lot of crazy you know
security things throughout my career too
also you know physically involved in a
lot of crazy stuff a lot of the stuff I
don't talk about I know Tim you don't
talk about the stuff that you deal with
as well but you know you just got to
take it one step at a time yeah you got
to be smart you got to make sure you're
not going to be a victim uh I started
you know learning self-defense in many
different ways and instances and that
also helps gives you gives you peace of
mind here but it's crazy out there and a
lot of the times people don't understand
like the crazy-ish that we had to go
through that I had to go through through
like from Chicago with the police
officers from you know interrogations
from getting jumped and attacked from
the the things that are happening at the
home here this is just like the
beginning of of a lot of others very
serious things to come so personal
defense is more important than ever I
also think just go kind of going back to
what his comment really was I took from
that you need to be the guy because we
just need figureheads saying these
things we don't need to be doing them
meanwhile contrast that with the left
who has infiltrated the medical
community they've infiltrated Taco Bell
they've infiltrated the education I'm
not kidding Starbucks they've edu
they've they've infiltrated all of these
different places right they're boots on
the ground they're going in and they are
getting it done and and then this
Viewpoint is just like well you just
need to be our guy and so be it you're
the rich guy you need to put yourself
out there and do it and it's like do you
do you guys not see that this is why
we're losing because they're over there
are doing the work that needs to be done
infiltrating in the community to change
the culture and we're just over here
like well you need to do it all for us
the story about Taco Bell was a guy
wearing a mask that said black lives
matter and his manager said you can't
wear a political mask at work and he
says I will not take this off and they
said then leave so he grabbed his phone
and he filmed himself saying they just
told me to leave they're firing me
because I wear black lives matter Taco
Bell panicked apologized and reinstated
him dude was willing to lose everything
for a mask with a logo on it meanwhile
there's a lot of people who are like
well you know I could but my worst case
scenario is I get yelled at by my boss
or my worst case scenario is that I
could lose my job and I have a family to
feed and I'm like I hear you man no I do
I do respect it I don't want people to
put their families at risk I get it but
I just hope you guys realize the left is
willing to literally burn down buildings
in Georgia leftists torched two houses
flipped the truck over and set it on
fire stolen from a guy they had gasoline
and explosives that's the length length
that they're willing to go and many
people here are like yeah but I could
lose my job it's like those dudes could
blow up right like there there's videos
of edible being set on fire they keep
doing it they're throwing explosives
they're being charged with Terror and
it's not going to stop them there is a
clear you know distinction between the
willingness to engage in conflict
between the two factions there's the
pro-america side that says we must we
must just calm down we must just mind
our own business keep our heads down and
let it all blow over and there are a lot
of people I'd say half or more that are
like no no I'm going to speak up I'm
going to stand up I will never back down
I can respect that but I I look at it
like
when we had Rick Santorum on and he said
we can't impeach Joe Biden no no we
can't do that we've got to play by the
rules we gotta and I'm like impeaching
Joe Biden doesn't accomplish anything
but a symbolic victory in the first
place if you're unwilling to just even
wave a sign saying we mad because it's
so it's decorum well then you're gonna
lose yeah yeah the the right has still
not learned the lesson that you have to
fight fire with fire and it like they're
so concerned about being uh moral right
well but we're the moral ones right I
think you can fight fire with fire with
a controlled burn they'll like burn a
stretch that the fire stops but I'm just
asking people on the right to Fight Fire
with water right we don't want a
destructive force right we just need
there to be some of it yeah and so
what's happening is if a bunch of people
are like look man I can't bail water
with you because I'll get too close to
the flames and you know I don't want to
risk hurting my hands I got kids to feed
it's like well there are people out here
who are currently being singed and
burned for you
and and many of them are respecting your
decision not to be involved and well but
and not just for you but for your
children that's what that's what that's
where and I again I understand and I try
to be empathetic to that view but I'm
like I have the children too and I'm out
there doing the hard work you know why
because I want my children to have a
better place for them when they grow up
why else do it right I mean if if it's
just for us well I mean by the time it
gets that bad maybe we'll you know help
see I think there's a whole wave of
people who are like watching you fight
the fire and they're over here being
like the fire is getting closer do a
better job I don't understand like right
I I think that there is such a sense
that it is not your responsibility and
that's where I come back to like if you
don't live by the values that you expect
everyone else to promote then like what
are you doing you're not helping at all
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time